a massive legal settlement will
compensate victims of the Las Vegas
massacre and their families MGM Resorts
will pay up to 800 million dollars
resolving lawsuits across several states
plaintiffs had claimed the hotel
conglomerate failed to protect concert
goers and prevent the shooter from
stockpiling weapons
Mireya Villarreal has reaction from
families who say the agreement will
finally allow them to heal
two years later nothing's changed as far
as good days and bad days
after seven surgeries shrapnel in her
brain a lost eye and what doctors called
a miraculous recovery from legal
blindness 30 year-old single mother
Chelsea Romo is ready to move forward I
have no choice I have two kids I have to
make it work Romo was one of the 22,000
people attending an outdoor Las Vegas
concert on October 1st 2017 when gunman
Steven paddock opened fire on the crowd
from windows of the Mandalay Bay Hotel
58 people died and more than 600 people
like Romo were wounded I have not been
able to go back to where right now I
have no medical insurance I have medical
bills I have a lot that I that I carry
now with my injuries the possible 800
million dollar settlement could impact
the more than 4,000 people currently
seeking damages attorney James France
represents Romo in about 200 other
victims I think it's the right step and
it's the right thing to do to make
restitution and not put the victims
through any more turmoil Romo says she
has more surgeries on the horizon but
knows better days are ahead of her I now
appreciate everything I see everything I
do so much more
MGM International Resorts which owns
Mandalay Bay released a statement that
says we our goal has always been to
resolve these matters or the community
the victims and their families can now
move forward we know that judges and
attorneys will now be working together
to figure out how
we'll divide this settlement money
between the more than 4,000 possible
victims involved Tony
Maria thank you